hey everyone Avenger stuff it into war
is now available on digital HD and
there's tons of bonus footage and
commentary from the directors and the
screenwriters that reveal huge details
about the film potentially setting up
major events for Avengers for now we've
already made some videos about two of
the deleted scenes but in this video
we're gonna break down all the other key
details that you missed from this
release welcome to new rockstars news is
our deep dive into all the biggest
stories this week so we're also gonna
talk about the Batman movie directed by
Matt Reeves Wonder Woman 1984 the latest
updates from this whole james gunn
guardians of the galaxy story that won't
divide any of you at all I'm sure my
starting me at the table or Maude
Garrett Tommy picked alright I'm not
allergic to any medicines thank you for
getting that out sure of the way because
I didn't want to have to ask but just
seasonal allergies dust mold pollen but
no medication let's see all right you're
still gonna have to do a physical if you
want to continue okay grace because we
all had to go through I brought some
blood he's we didn't need the blood
bringing blood well then I've got free
blood on Lancashire well let's dive into
this guys it's our top story the release
of adventures infinity war currently on
digital HD soon on blu-ray
now this release includes a fascinating
set of deleted footage and filmmakers
commentary that we have reviewed for you
and let's run down the big reveals that
kind of changed the way we look at this
movie and possibly next year's follow-up
of interest for title still unknown now
the first major reveal was the nature of
the Infinity stones as discussed in the
commentary by the director and the
writers they explained that the reality
stone wouldn't be enough for Thanos to
redefine realities so that half of
existence was just gone with that one
stone alone all six are needed to do
something to that magnitude but the
reality stones power in this movie is
that it can create temporary illusions I
know it's come it yeah it reality and
then that's just oh you can get I love
it it's like there's infinite
possibilities but we have to put
parameters and boundaries on it right
you can become ribbon you're a blast can
be turned into bubbles oh yeah and so
like basically that's not an illusion
that is literally a Rhema nipple ation
yeah well okay fine yeah
it's like yeah changing your current
perception of reality which I guess is a
is a power that is interesting it's just
unfortunate like out so many of the
other infinity students we got to see
their powers in different cool ways so
that's one just kind of felt like and
this and I guess it appeared in those
more the dark world but I think this
kind of gets to the next point is that
the screenwriters said that six Infinity
stones was a really challenging number
of MacGuffins for one movie and the way
they got around and I think there's
actually a really clever way to
structure in this story is by linking
the time stone in the mind stone with
the characters so that like your focus
on that MacGuffin of the mind stone is
just think about vision safety and the
same with dr. change at the time stone
and then with the power stone they
completely decided to cut the zantar
sequence that would have given Danis the
power stone because at the end of the
day it would have been redundant with
how he got the reality stone where they
just kind of show him in the middle of
the battle he's already got it we would
have had basically two movies like that
where the Guardians show up after you
know the battle so I think that was like
a smart way to do it they start the
movie in the middle yes that's what they
say that that's the secret to good
storytelling right start in the middle
start in the middle
that's way to who said that who said
that yeah hey Mill author of the hit
film Christopher Robin in theaters now
today did you I believe you it's I don't
know they this is an interesting detail
about Infinity stones if you look
closely in the opening fight with Anacin
Hulk you can see that Thanos isn't using
the Infinity stone when he beats down
Hulk a ruse actually called Thanos the
Genghis Khan of the Marvel Universe I
can like that description he's a
conqueror of worlds and a more polished
fighter than anything Avengers would be
so it makes sense that he wouldn't need
a special power which it's helpful to
see him as the savage brute and he's
ever known it's a guy who can bring down
the Hulk how do these details like
change the way you look at the nose I I
mean I think it just solidifies more and
more that this wasn't an Avengers maybe
this was a fairness movie and that it's
fleshed out he's character so much more
and that it was able to kind of provide
even more layers I guess with him and
trying to understand him a little bit
more with a movie like that with so many
characters
with so many possibilities with so many
you know unlimited confines of what
these stones can potentially do I think
it was kind of nice to just be like oh
don't get too carried away you know like
people are talking about I think with
Stephen Colbert brought up well why
didn't send us just instead of you know
having the population double the
resources and these are really
legitimate and you know fair questions I
think they're like great great question
let's explain why and how and like cause
more about or more explanations did were
any of these things sort of necessary
knowing it when watching the movie no I
think they did a good job in kind of
like trimming the fat but it's this
thing where it's like if you keep
digging you'll keep getting more and
more answers and I loved it there were
so brothers I've got them yeah they've
done the research
III agree completely use your said mod I
think like the best bonus features on a
movie are when you realize that they're
completely unnecessary like they're fun
to know but you did not need them at all
like that that's a sign that the film
was well done in the first place yeah
and I think when you look at like they
enosis journey in this movie this is
something that Joe Russo has said they
mapped out the hero's journey of this
movie on fan houses character art like
the story beats of the whole movie are
Thanos's heroic beats if you consider
him a hero I guess in this version and I
do love it and you do that's you've been
trying to snack home daddy fan fan love
my daddy and he start the play no stick
mean not everyone everyone's thick no
one is that's true that was a damn
Daniel did they graduate yeah can we get
awareness check the if you're watching
collar damn damn damn
what happened dear it was the shoes
taken away in the van all right the
second big detail revealed in the
commentary concerned how Thanos knew who
Tony Stark was that was a question that
you know we were kind of struggling with
that while you guys were asking was it
the reality stone or was it the soul
stone that kind of give him gave him
insight to read his mind or something
well according to the filmmaker Stannis
and Tony share an intellect and a
futurist mindset they're kind of like
like-minded people and they're both used
to be in kind of the smartest ones in
the room which when Yuri watches it's
like yeah that totally makes sense
sothe Anna's being aware of Tony Stark
as the guy who thwarted his battle the
New York plan remember in the first
Avengers he saw this guy this Iron Man
figure throwing a nuke at the Chitauri
army through the wormhole and that's not
something you'd forget yeah that's
something still kind of like respect
like this guy was able to like really
strike a blow at me and I'm not gonna
forget this guy so he's kind of been
keeping tabs on them and that's why when
we see him on Titan Thanos continues to
beat Stark to death even though remember
killing stark wouldn't necessarily give
him an infinity stone in that moment he
recognizes the parallels sees him as the
true threat yeah so what do you guys
think of these similarities between
Dennis and Iron Man does that set up
Iron Man is gonna be like maybe the the
true hero who will bring down Thanos in
the final step I think it sets up Iron
Man to actually be one of the few
permanent deaths in the fourth movie
well yeah I see I think I think it and
probably the one who ends up defeating
Thanos but dies in the process the
ultimate sign of sacrifice mmm
sacrifice yourself to save everyone
yeah like Jesus whoa what do you do coal
iron man like tiny tiny Jesus not in
Christ I don't know though because
they're also setting up their like
peppers might have a baby and like
really wants to do it come home she's
clucky
I think the Marvel movies I am more in
the mark the Marvel movies aren't that
sadder they would be like he's about to
be a dad let's kill him
I think the status will get in the
marble you don't know where the
ant-man's daughter made it yet do we
there dangling that carrot over us I
really like flushing out these two
characters when you realize that they
have so much more in common than you
recognize and this is what Marvel does a
really good job with their villains and
that is they normalize them in a way
where you can kind of reckon recognize
similar features like kill kill monger
did an amazing job with that as well
it's like oh I understand him so no so I
get it
but even low-key kind of but I do really
like the fact that you know Tony Stark
is hyper intelligent and a really really
smart thing to do like obviously
knowledge is power and the more you
learn about your enemy the more power
you have over them and I think that this
literally came to a head in this
particular moment where it was like you
know I liked this moment between them
yeah and if you think like the Marvel
characters have the Marvel characters in
the comics the villains their
motivations are often pretty
one-dimensional like Thanos as this
whole idea of like why didn't they know
to double the resources like well
because in the original comics they
didn't think that you know these movies
would be made into like just like here's
an interesting thing that might sell a
lot of comic issues what he wants to do
yeah just make a guy who could snap away
half the universe yeah that could be
interesting like I'd be curious to know
exactly how many people read comics in
the 80s and 90s and 70s like there's no
way obviously that it says as many
billion people now who are reading
watching okay it's it's a tiny by
comparison number of people maybe I
don't know a million people they're
really fun you know you could research
it probably yeah yeah but I think when
you're reading a comic you don't really
need necessarily that much depth with
your villains so they've had to go back
and like add so much more they've done a
really good job at least with Danis to
give a lot of dimension and weight and
emotional backing to that character so
that we kind of
curious the same way we were with kill
monger to see what would happen if he
did succeed my thing is as well this
isn't the first time we've had a Marvel
villain want to wipe out to start again
that was Ultron's entire point yeah
destroy it and then we can rewrite the
Phoenix effect we can be reborn from
like the ashes
sothank that makes sense like less is
more I don't think they're like hey
let's overpopulate everything and I
can't understand it the planet-sized the
mass all of that is not going to expand
as well I mean people are we can do that
with the Infinity stones but it's like
yeah if the earth is gonna stay the same
size and then you just double everything
then that would collapse as well
eventually they're gonna make their way
back up to that overpopulation so
they're just be so many Pete's
impossible there's impossible to have
too many people well another cool detail
that came out is the filmmakers also
waited on how they chose which heroes
would fade and thanasis snap at the end
of the movie they said that for them it
was a matter of identifying which heroes
they wanted to play an active role in
the final installment and then after
that identifying which foil characters
whose deaths would deliver the strongest
emotional death punch to them so for
example in terms of cap story arcs so
much as journey as monkey right do you
know which one I cried over do you know
which which fizzle out got me the
hardest great yeah great was it for me
yeah that got me I was like oh no just
hearing like Bradley Cooper's voice
break his rocket racoon I was like see
ya oh so he's having a teary by thenns
and when Tom came around I was like take
a ticket mate I'm already done yeah it
was interesting that they had a Koi a
watch same black panther fade away even
though black panther is a bigger
character but he's thinking you know
Khoya is mine her whole existence has
been devout protecting the king so to
see the king fade away in her and her
fingertips it's like what a what a
powerful thing for her in something that
could potentially motivate her more than
like if black panther saw a koi a fade
away he's got a lot of things on his
mind rather than just like one person
yeah so it's interesting that like we
had this moment with tony stark seeing
spider-man fade away so like what do you
guys think that means of their
relationship why is it so important that
Tony Stark see spider-man fade when it
comes to like what could happen next for
him because he's got babies on the brain
already yeah and then this is like a
surrogates
and then now he's failed him in like
this now this is a question you had to a
son absolutely yeah and he chose to
mentor him he's been keeping a close eye
basically on his entire career he's the
one who's been putting you know
parameters on him you know you can't
leave New York you can't come to space
with me
yeah conversations that every father has
with his surrogates my dad sat me on his
knee and had the same conversation last
week you're not coming his face son
we're not going to space not today but
he went he's up there with that Tesla
we're gonna get your dad if you get a
new suit you could probably join in it's
all it comes down to dude it's tough the
summer I don't have my summer body ready
anyway I love how like it wasn't overt
in the movie right like their work no
one said the word daddy issues in terms
of the relationship as far as I can
remember it seemed like pretty subtle
just in their behavior and the way they
related to each other and then just that
little thing at the beginning where he's
talking with Pepper Potts about like the
future and wanting to have a family
so like ending in his final moment of
seeing your surrogate son disappear make
something like well could I ever be
responsible enough to like protect kids
that's why I think it was his one
weakness yeah you know he was so
responsible for Peter that that was I
you could see that as he's ultimately
failing and I think that's the
motivation needed to just be relentless
and you're right I think tell me you've
hit a nail in the head because of that
that's gonna be the thing where he was
happy to sacrifice himself if it means
bringing back Peter yeah I can see that
for sure the commentary also shed light
on the fates of supporting characters
from thor ragnarok like valkyrie Corgan
meek that a lot of you guys been asking
about we didn't see them die per se but
they could have been among the half of
the refugees that Thanos presumably
spared from the as guardianship at the
beginning book kill half not all but the
filmmakers have confirmed that the
Asgardians did escape and they repeated
that Valkyrie was among them Joe
resource said that in past but when it
comes to the others this one screen
artists said all I could say is pray for
course I will whatever I need to do
don't touch Cole gets personal if you do
that it's getting personal yeah I mean
well do you guys think this is just like
a joke think they have
real plans for them an infinity or is it
just something like mm we just don't
want to say either way but they'll
probably show up in the future themes I
think that they don't I think they have
all this planned out I think they know
exactly what's going to happen and they
just love teasing stuff and saying like
sure don't expect this but never give up
hope on it such a hard thing I think
they need a little bit of breathing room
I don't think they can make all the
decisions right now I think they need to
hold a lot of cards to their chest
because if they kind of define and put
out there who does make it and who
doesn't then it's like that's locked in
stone yeah and then people like us will
start making predictions based off of
this improv yeah because man all you
gotta do the movie and as The Hollywood
Reporter says ruin it for the fans yes
we never forget Hollywood Reporter what
a joke rag we're hanging a bi threat to
well let us know in the comments below
what you find most interesting about
this new information what questions you
still have oh sure the fact that cap was
I'm gonna have his big entrance in the
final battle as well and then he was
going to be in not much of the movie at
all and he was supposed to be the huge
reveal and the Russo brothers loves the
fact that he was going to come in with
his high and mighty moment that they
ended up giving to Thor because the
whole big feedback was we need more cap
there's no enough cap and they're like
okay so they had to ride him in far more
of the movie I agree I think having him
only come in at the last act I would be
devastated yeah I agree
oh and I just kept with a beard oh hell
yeah I need more of that there's a and
you just saw something right before we
start shooting about like how they got
the arm
yeah apparently the Russo brothers have
been asked a lot how they got Tom
Holland to have the hair stand up when
he gets his spidey sense a lot of people
were like that was ccgi right never CGI
they legitimately without like any
jerking feeling behind it what am I
trying to say there that was serious
when they responded with someone was
actually blowing into Tom's ear they
were trying to give
yeah they got the hottest so Tommy you
were in here last week we got a new fun
thing for our punishment okay I think
you're gonna okay so our question is in
Avengers infinity war what phrase is on
the t-shirt worn by Peter Parker at the
beginning of the movie okay all of our
answers are in the bucket and just to
remind you guys the winner as decided by
our judges whoever gets the closest will
get to read our goodbyes at the end of
the episode and after we reveal the
answer and the loser will have to be the
latest inductee to our brand-new trivia
punishment the gif of shame whoa gif of
shame all right let's uh we'll get to
that later but let's move on okay so a
quick update from some other news that
came out this week
the Batman director Matt Reeves was
asked about the project this week it's a
movie that keeps really getting delayed
and delayed delayed at some point Ben
Affleck was gonna be writer director but
he's still kind of attached to the
project we don't really know but he Matt
Reeves said that a new draft of the
script is coming in the next few weeks
and he said that although he did read a
lot of Batman comics for research in its
creative process the story this movie
will not be an origin story and it will
not be an adaptation of Frank Miller's
Batman near one like many of us thought
it would Reeves said that the movie will
instead be an emotional story that
focuses on Batman being the world's
greatest detective
it'll be an aura driven story in which
Batman is investigating a particular
case
says out into the world of Gotham
yesterday Ben Affleck is still involved
but it's just too early to talk in which
capacity is involved so yeah it's still
happening basically is it take away
there
I mean feel better more nervous about it
I just don't understand like do we need
another dark Batman I actually really
like the noir style behind it I think
especially compared to Ben Affleck's
Justice League and where we just saw him
where it was aliens and explosions in
the end of the world in the end of the
universe
I like scaling it back again I kind of
like it when Gotham had problems and it
was up to him to kind of like figure it
out no good detective story that's a
good detective mystery like a Chinatown
type thing you know like Batman with a
tape over his nose solving Los Angeles
has water problems the dirty that's my
man yeah that's there's your movie Matt
Reeves did give me my money back is
gonna be like 74 by the time they start
perfect age for a you know Dark Knight
Returns Batman yeah yeah you know who
should play Batman Alex Trebek if he
leaves jeopardy
he needs work it'll be so close yes the
questions matter he's quite the
detective
you gotta respond with the questions he
gives the answers
okay well another update from this week
Wonder Woman 1984 a director patty
Jenkins posted a set photo on social
media showing Pedro Pascal's character
who's still in named he can be seen in
the back of a car with a 80s hair cut
and pinstripe suit kinda hard to
recognize he also appears to be on a TV
monitor you know that's the the frame of
this is within a TV monitor which looks
like it could be one of those TV screens
of Dianna sees in that other set photo
that jenkins release it's all connected
there is some speculation that Pascal
could be playing Maxwell Lord he's a
businessman who funded the Justice
League in the comics he later becomes
like a villain with mind controlling
powers and won't have to kill him in
order to free Superman from his mental
grip speculation there's not many clues
just like oh he looks rich it could be
him and it's a character we haven't seen
before and last week we actually learned
that joining the cast will be gabriella
wilde Ravi Patel and Natasha Rothwell
from insecurity she's like my favorite
part of that show good-looking cast here
we you just planted two seed by I'm
saying that Diana had to save Superman
Henry Cavill and gal gadot
when are we getting that happening and
throwing a little bit of triangle action
with Steve Rogers they're like in real
life in our world no in the movie but
what if it happens in our world too and
then everyone can be married and I
already married I think she's got two
kids
henry cavill single they see okay well
happy happy my day oh I'm not going away
well bringing the jokes to a screeching
halt here we want to update you on this
James Gunn's story and yeah you know
it's hard to talk about this on this
channel because we typically avoid
controversial subject subjects like a
plague
especially where tensions are so hot and
there's you know you're all very divided
on it but these are figures of movies
that are important to you guys and we
want to know what happens with guard
ease
Volume three so here's a quick update
that happened the full cast of guardians
of the galaxy hosted an open letter in
defense of director James Gunn whom
remember Disney fired two weeks ago
after several of guns old tweets went
around he had made some pretty obscene
jokes relating to issues like rape and
pedophilia and despite apologizing for
them long before this blew up and he
really sees his behavior before it came
to be controversial again some online
political enemies of gun dug him up and
spread them around trying to get him
fired and Disney gave to that pressure
and and they fired a gun which some of
you agreed with that decision some of
you don't they fired gun Guardians cast
I'll sign this letter and they all
shared it on their individual accounts
and they agreed that guns jokes were
offensive they do not stand by those
jokes but they defended his current
character that as they worked them in
the past six or so years and they
likened his transformation to the themes
of redemption that the guardians movies
have really been all about which I can
see that but despite this Disney appears
to be standing by its decision and
insider reports are saying that
executives like Alan horn and Bob Iger
have no intention to rehire Gunn so
there you go that's that's the update
there and you know I have mixed feelings
on this I'm not gonna go too far into it
you can follow me on Twitter for some of
my political opinions but you guys
follow me for like more nerd insight
news I'll just say that it's it's a
little worrisome when like people who
aren't comedians are kind of making
category decisions about like what you
can and cannot make jokes about and are
like getting people fired for that on
both sides but I you know I I have had
jobs before where I've gone back and
like deleted old things I said on
Twitter you know it's it's kind of a
no-brainer thing that I've done I think
is pretty fair to say no one is exactly
the same person though they were 10
years ago we all grow we all evolve we
all learn the error of our ways but at
the same time the humor that was
established 10 years ago isn't the same
humor PC culture didn't exist 10 years
ago and the thing with James Gunn's
comments is he was saying it out loud he
wasn't saying it to a person should he
have said those particular comments to a
person I find that that's a lot more
severe because it's something with
intent this is just more about bad humor
a palling humor
but it was kind of out there to the
world not targeted you've got someone
like Johnny Depp who has struck a woman
who has you know done a bunch of things
like that and yet he's still on
fantastic beasts and where to find them
I think that in comparison Johnny Depp's
actions are deplorable and that should
have an effect the other thing is these
tweets existed when Disney hired him
yeah it was kind of on Disney to go back
through it and like fleece him out for
sure if he if James had written these
tweets while under the employment of
Disney I absolutely get it but they
existed before and then they also are
kind of appeasing exactly what the right
alt people wanted and that was like
basically career sabotage they went with
the intention to destroy gun and then by
Disney saying well yeah I mean sure it's
like well who's next and that's like
this yeah this revenge culture that
we're also putting it and putting out
there so yeah I don't think it's fair I
think you're allowed to change he's
proved himself completely
he's absolutely apologized for it and I
think Disney has a knee-jerk reaction in
a very sensitive time yeah and I think
they were under pressure I think from
the other side what's like well you
fired fired Roseanne Barr I think
there's a world of difference between
like being unapologetic and repeatedly
being warned and she was a joke and she
puts out conspiracy theories that she
believes that are dangerous to all of us
this is not just like people target she
was like there's people in these
conspiracy theories that show up to the
White House with guns because they seem
crazy and she amplifies it willingly cuz
she believes that that's not safe
but she's current climate as well this
is something she used to do ten years
ago and now she's changed which is
flourish and she's embarrassed about
that she's perpetuating it to this day
yeah and if you want my opinion I will
be at the burgundy room in Hollywood
tonight from 9:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m. and
I will tell you all about this privately
and that's a completely respectful to
keep your opinions private and yeah
whatever ends up having with James Gunn
this guy's with in many circles a martyr
who they'll go watch whatever movie he
makes next he's still super talented and
you know he has lots of options so we'll
see what happens from this and again
there's no you know there's there's lots
of opinions here so let's be respectful
in the comments and and to us you can
disagree with us and still like what we
do
and I have a lot deeper political
opinions about this that I could have
gone into but I I don't want to bother
you well you could roast me on what you
think I would probably say yes neck
beard he loves James good let's move on
to the lightning round
this week you guys tweeted some
questions oh yeah I'm gonna fire my
co-host and they have to answer them as
quickly and without hesitation as
possible okay are we ready hang on wait
your guns okay here we go here's a
question for you at kc g filio wants to
know thoughts on the henry cavill
forearm reload that magic but to me it
was it was the closest thing I've ever
seen to a magic show my parents forbid
magic in her house as a child so for me
I loved it yeah he's either getting
harassed about it and doesn't want to do
it the movies been under I'm still
loading my own so it's not really
anything he's just goes okay fine look
he's got a I'm also turned on by here we
go
Joel's Worth wants to know what type of
droid would you be in the Star Wars
universe ah probably a protocol droid I
don't know if I could be an astromech
because I can't really fix things and
not hands on but I talk a lot so there
you go
I don't know if I'm fluent in over six
million forms of communication to
English and Australian which is a
different language that's I can speak
like a phrase in about nine different
languages a seven what is conversational
in nine languages what I'm hearing I
learned a phrase called dipper toddlers
were nappies what a friend lied to me
but I don't dip it uh it sounded like
she made it up Rams diaper gosh guys
okay I guess I do speak a completely
different language protocol droid
kangaroo and then there's three
questions here well I don't have
prepared answers to any of them so fire
any one of them at me and I'll give you
pure honesty alright he's one from size
stocks he says would you rather be stuck
at giant size or that really all could
child size from okay I could do either
those for a week probably I wouldn't
want to be Giants I don't think so yeah
dole people I'd rather be short cuz like
yeah I feel like I'm already like a
couple inches taller than average height
and like being super tall you can't fit
in anywhere you go you got a walk
you can't take a car and you can't pin
at the doors yeah not interested and
it's you seem to have trouble breathing
you were talking about you now yeah
that's just because alcohol is so yeah
during these tapings alright well now
comes a 15-second shout out where each
of us is 15 seconds to shout out plug or
ramble about anything in the world we
want mod why don't you start so last
week I told you about the video game I
was playing then I bought a new one
shadow of war I know I'm a little bit
behind but it's the second installment
for shadow of Mordor it's basically set
in the law of the Rings universe I've
been killing so many orcs in or require
it's been amazing that's kind of my 15
seconds guys
I've just been spending a lot of time
killing orcs hey what awkward I shout
out I'm gonna shout out my two friends
getting married in the next
my friend Andy Connor is getting married
and my friend Colin Hughes is getting
there yeah you have two friends yeah
both my friends are getting married so
now I have zero unmarried friends and
only I am unmarried and I am the
loneliest boy and I will always be
lonely always I'm so lonely
Oh even quite that maybe we have a nice
moment there Cory
do you America anymore that's Team
America that's not even team Australia
being offensive
oh yeah well my shout out might run
longer than 15 seconds so bear with me
but I want to address probably the most
common question we receive here in new
rock stars hi if you follow this channel
you might wonder why we cover some
properties and not others like why do we
talk so much about infinity war in the
Nolan Nolan Batman movies that came out
ten years ago and not just stuff like
Luke Cage season two that we've done
trailer breakdowns for why the hell did
I make a video about how the cars from
Pixar have sex it's not the exhaust pipe
I honestly appreciate so that's why but
we have an answer we go watch that video
talk the love some of those cars have
beards Maude look I really appreciate
you guys so much I love the fact that
you guys watch our channel and they're
so supportive with your feedback I
really feel like I owe you guys some
transparency because you give us so much
of your time so I don't want to like not
give you guys the truth so whether you
subscribe to us for our Marvel videos or
Star Wars or Game of Thrones or for a
new home after SourceFed nerd and salmon
mod started hosting with us or to catch
a glimpse of a bottom line over here in
the wild whatever the reason you can
obviously obviously I think you guys
know this it's impossible for a hundred
percent of our videos to appeal to each
of you so unlike the herds over at the
logging or you're a diverse minded bunch
you know it's not like we're gonna get a
hundred percent like ratio in all of our
videos and that's okay that's what makes
you guys great thank you so much for
your patience and supporting us as much
as you do and I would love to cover
everything that each of you are
interested in but this operation is a
lot smaller than it seems we tricked you
this is all taking place in Hank Pym
shrunken down lab it's
Timken village at best we have two
amazing editors Devin over here in Aaron
as well they rotate in they work their
asses off to make a video output
possible and they're supported by some
hard-working freelance editors we also
have great hosts like mod and Tommy also
Phillip and Sam and DJ who come in and
they enrich this channel so much DJ
there's also we also have a part-time
manager who works miracles with
scheduling and budgets and we have a
couple of the people who help us out in
smaller ways but really it's only one of
us who's in the office for a full work
week and I'm like that's me you're gonna
be a full-time yeah yeah it's it's me
and I'm not complaining I love my job
and I love being able to like host with
you guys and and being able to come in
every day and do what I do but really I
only have time to like write and produce
this show here plus three or four maybe
other videos a week I'm pricing my home
and I'm trying to just make sure all
those videos are at the depth and
production value that you guys deserve
like we I feel like that's what
separates new rock stars and the rest we
aim to put quality over quantity we
could just make 20 videos a week but
like they'd all be kind of crappy so we
don't want to do that but in order to
hit that sweet spot I can't just make
videos about whatever I want I can't be
selfish I gotta focus on the stuff that
I'm into that's also hopefully something
millions of people are desperately
searching for on YouTube according to
the best research data that non-existent
budgets can buy so when we get stuck
doing breakdowns of episode after
episode of a niche TV series or a
half-hour video about a TV season a show
that isn't a ratings Goliath like Game
of Thrones so pretty much anything
that's not Game of Thrones each of those
videos cost us hundreds of dollars I'm
not kidding sometimes as thousands of
dollars depending on how long the video
is and especially at this crazy YouTube
ad pocalypse randomly do monetize our
videos like they did with AMC in The
Walking Dead videos we lose all that
money it's not just like oh we took a
hit we lost that now it would be great
if we had a cache burning parent company
that could just subsidize all these kind
of losses like some channels do good for
them that's not how our budget works
we're we have considered a 100% patron
funded model that'd be great but I don't
know in this company that's above my pay
grade I don't make those decisions
simply right now if our videos don't
blow
not just if they don't do well if they
don't blow up we don't make money we
lose our jobs now sometimes we can roll
the dice with like with a one-off video
about a big movie or trailer that comes
out because sometimes there is a silent
majority of fans who like crave that
stuff that's honestly how we started
covering Pixar our Incredibles video
blew up and that also includes videos
about Lightning McQueen sex life watch a
video another plug for that so honestly
I want you guys to know I'm obsessed
with Luke Cage and Westworld Legion
Handmaid's Tale and I'm sure the gifted
and cloak-and-dagger and all these other
shows that you want us to break down are
great but it would just be nuts for us
to spend our limited resources on niche
content like that over movie franchises
with massive global followings that
allow this channel to even exist in the
first place so I'll never say never when
it comes to a Luke Cage season 2 video
but if we don't do one or if we stop
making videos about a TV show or a movie
series that you really love all the
above reasons are why it's not that I
don't care it's really we just don't
have the time or resources to do
everything as much as we would love to
be able to do everything could be
everything to everyone forever and ever
that's about 15 seconds nailed it can I
just say real quickly with my youtube
channel my gosh algorithms are so off so
apparently someone was like Oh YouTube
just unsubscribe me from geek balm for
no reason and so I put the word out
going hey if you're subscribe to geek
balm do you just want to check if you're
still subscribed 50% of the people came
back and said I had been unsubscribed
I've just realized housands of
subscribers from that in fact I went
over a hundred thousand I'm about to dip
back under after like six or eight
months after going over yeah that just
dis it's like I'm seriously someone
clicked the Pharos click on my
subscriber and half of them are
disappearing so there's a lot of things
that are outside of our control in like
unfortunate I hate having to play the
numbers game because we just love
creating content about stuff that we
love but like to exist in the first
place we have to play the numbers game a
little bit and that's just the reality
but hopefully it seems like you guys are
kind of happy with what we've been doing
and and if we just feel free to tweet us
but just like there that's your reason
why if we don't cover something that you
thought we would also if you really find
that there is a lack of like
cloak-and-dagger breakdowns or your
favorite niche show think about doing it
yourself
yeah yes and and tweet us about it cuz
like we're not against like giving you a
shout out because we're part of a
community here maybe 15 seconds yeah
mm-hmm maybe you could get a job working
for us if it blows up money to pay
people but me and check out Thursday's
when I'll be releasing my puppy dog pal
breakdown videos for all you Disney
Junior fans out there I'm doing puppy
dog pals the new Muppet Babies and the
alphabet kids I feel that you are the
one person that should not be doing
children's television program I resent
that Bart I'm great with kids
well let's move on to our trivia answer
so just to remind us what the question
was it was like what shirt is a Peter
Parker wearing at the beginning of initi
so let's go down the line and see what
we said okay I have mod hmm I have
Eric's and it says to infinity and
beyond and then just so in case you
didn't know it has a line to the word
infinity and says pun you get it because
it's a pun well Tommy said or it's Nick
T I should say said impeach Trump which
are his words
that's Peter Parker's where it's not man
but that is yeah that's that's not even
that's not that's not me that's that's
Tom how actors choice very woke he's in
that Cortez's district yeah Eric says I
lost an election are you sure I'm
positive which I know as a certain
writer in homecoming I don't know a
surety I think it's a lettuce the taste
of sadness
what yep lettuce the taste of it's well
imagine that that says let us taste the
sadness but I'd yeah I do remember
seeing that we talked about that before
I just should say let us eat the taster
sad what does it taste like
sans I'm gonna try vegetable this week
well he was tasting sadness at the end
of the movie for sure
we were eating that sadness out Robert
Downey jr. did a line of Tom Hollands
ashes after that he really died right no
I want you to be with me forever
loser that's the bottom line that's
mommy has to join the gif of shame shame
shame shame what a great graphic oh so
great
okay so Tom this is how this works you
have to draw a task or physical gesture
from this container and you must
repeatedly make this motion throughout
the end of the video while the goodbyes
are happening I'll chant shame at you
and later we will turn that into an
animated gif or Jif I know one of these
like a jiff yeah we pronounced Yeti and
we're gonna blast out that animated gif
on social media yeah i'ma blast you with
my gif gif up in your face tonight right
oh come on please don't be the truffle
shuffle that's just gonna pretend you're
surrounded by butterflies made of
chocolate eat them okay that's your kid
but is that what you would do if you
were surrounded by butterflies made of
chocolate yeah I wouldn't go holy Sh
alright so here we go jump to that yeah
you can start right
oh my god it's about if I made of
chocolate my gosh when you eat chocolate
butterflies without hands it looks like
the final scene of Jurassic Park yeah
when dinosaurs ruled the earth
[Laughter]
yeah and beyond thanks watching this
week's episode of new rock stars news
hey big shout out to Eric Voss EI vas if
you wanna check him out on social medias
I'm Lourdes Garrett at Maude Garrett and
then we got Tommy who bottom line back
tail deer at Tommy Beck's called
how those chocolate butterflies back
told mm-hmm tastes like larvae you back
told me that's the show told you so hey
if you really want to subscribe to geek
grime as well if you haven't subscribed
to New York cells or if you thought you
did subscribed and then YouTube's
grabbed you and he had no idea make sure
you just click those buttons again
that'd be real sweet and comment down
below tweet this link because we put up
new videos every single Friday so
retweet it share around the internet and
yeah you're gonna keep getting a lot of
videos and now you know they're made
with blood sweat and learn
it's Jeff Jeff oh my gosh Jeff and tank
I need to have a coming I love a good
2001 call so the point is there's two
hot girls and they look alive